david bonjour alors malgré les multiples
interdictions de manifester à paris
aujourd'hui les gilet jaune on est ce
qu'ils ont répondu présent effectivement
samantha vous l'avez évoqué de
nombreuses interdictions de manifester
mais les jaunes ont répondu présent à
cette à ce rassemblement a déclaré à la
presse prêt auprès de la préfecture de
police un important dispositif de
sécurité a encore une fois été mise en
place par le préfet l'allemand un
dispositif de sécurité disons le
disproportionné par rapport au nombre de
manifestants à présent tout cas le
cortège s'est élancé 1 2 puis à la place
de la nation pour se rendre vers bagnols
appuyez ensuite jusqu'au but de chaumont
en point final de ce rassemblement je me
trouve actuellement avec l'organisatrice
la co organisatrice de cet acte 66
aurait dit de wendel aurélie est ce que
vous attendiez à ce que le mouvement des
légions de vioreau temps dans le temps
aujourd'hui on aurait espéré qu'ils
aient pas nécessité ce que ça dure
autant de temps puisque si on est là
c'est que justement jusqu'à présent on
n'a pas obtenu grand chose presque même
rien obtenu on assiste à une destruction
du service public on assiste à une
destruction des droits du citoyen rien
n'est fait pour pour le climat alors que
c'est une urgence et que l'urgence est
reconnu donc il ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie
aussi actuellement en politique et le
fait est que si les gilet jaune sont
encore dans la rue aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'il nécessité pour protéger les
droits du citoyen et de voir autant d'
interdiction de manifester puisque on le
rappelle aujourd'hui à trois
manifestations devaient être déclarés
auprès de la préfecture de voir cette
elles ont été cette interdiction qu'est
ce que ça vous évoque en fait c'est
quand on parle de casse de droits du
citoyen c'est ça c'est à dire que
légalement il ya trois ministres hâtif
qui a permis de faire passer ces pots
anti casseurs qui fait que dans les
faits il ya bel et bien les
interdictions de manifester c'est à dire
que vous déclarez une manifestation
autrefois c'était une déclaration ce
n'était pas une permission qui était
donné on déclare une manif juste pour
qu'elle soit sécurisée pour protéger les
riverains mais également les
manifestants or actuellement ça équivaut
à une permission qui est donnée parce
que l'interdiction est placé sur des
endroits ou non et malheureusement dans
les faits vous est décalé sur des
quartiers qui n'ont plus vraiment de
sens parce que quand je vois la
manifestation du centre de paris c'était
des lieux stratégiques de pouvoir qui
avaient été sélectionnés parce qu'il y
avait un message à faire passer
et là le message peut pas être passé
puisque les lieux sont interdits donc
c'est bel et bien une interdiction de
manifester dans les faits qu'elle égale
mais qui est pas très légitime
merci beaucoup et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions là vous l'aurez compris à les
jeunes sont toujours motivés en tout cas
pour revendiquer leurs droits et ses
revendications qui sont toujours là même
la dissolution de l'assemblée elle
nationale la création également d' états
généraux un citoyen afin qu'ils puissent
ré écrire une constitution
voilà en tout cas le cortège s'est
élancé depuis 14h30 et va se rendre
jusque aux buttes chaumont
merci beaucoup des villes khalifa pour
toutes ces précisions